thank you
good afternoon members members of the
public officers and welcome to this
southeast area planning committee
meeting on wednesday the 30th september
2020
my name is councillor michael helm i am
the vice chairman of this committee
deputising for the chairman councillor
richard
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april
in the response to the kovit 19
situation and there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
first of all please may ask everyone
present at this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted
and your video feed off when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noise and
avoid any unintentional disturbance
the meeting is being hosted remotely and
streamed live
and recorded and by being in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak
and that you have to or you have to
leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
please do not use the raised hand
function as this will
is not available on all members devices
when speaking refer to agenda paper
please ensure your reference a page or
paragraph number
and last if members need to leave the
meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function to signify
you need to leave the meeting now my ask
officers taking part in the meeting to
introduce themselves starting mr lee
mr lee thank you chairman i am a
matthew lee lead specialist place and
chief planos here at warden district
council thank you
michael johnson thank you chairman
michael johnson um development
management lead specialist
thank you hannah bells
good afternoon i'm hannah bowles a
specialist in development management
thank you berna good afternoon members
bernie casey clark to the meeting
thank you varna my i have the apologies
for absence please
uh chairman i'll take a roll call of
four members
sorry thank you chairman members i will
call your names in alphabetical order
starting with councillor bassinger
and he said that if he wasn't here for
me to send his apologies i think he's
having a meeting
at mdc thank you very much cancer stamp
counselor biel
councillor bill
okay we'll move on members councillor
bell
yes i'm president bernard thank you
counselor boys
president thank you casa chana
hello bernar good morning everyone i'm
present thank you council
casted fluker
caster fluker
council helm president
yes i'm president i'm here thank you
casper schemes
cancer schemes
cancer stamp hi berna hi members i'm
here
thank you thank you chairman now
now may i ask any members in attendance
to introduce themselves
please
good afternoon councillor bamford
thank you thank you chairman
thank you apologists for absence please
bernard
thank you chairman councillor bassinger
and councillor duke have sent apologies
for absence
okay thank you very much
uh minutes it's recommended the minutes
of the meeting held on the 2nd of
september 2020 panel
found on pages 7 to 20 are approved as a
true accurate record
iso move if you wish to second that
motion please turn on your video
unboot your microphone and state your
name now please i'll second that
chairman councillor penny channel
thank you if any members wishes to raise
any masses of accuracy please use the
chat function to indicate and i will
invite you to speak
everybody happy
great great german thank you
nature of any disposal pecuniary
interests
other peculiar interests and
non-pecuniary interests related isis of
business on the agenda having regard to
paragraph
six to eight inclusive the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare
please use the chat function now to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
anybody can channel chairman
yeah um thank you chairman uh my normal
one chairman uh
must declare a non-pecuniary um item and
i'm also a member of essex county
council
and of course that is a council team
regarding planning applications on
matters of highways access
education and anything really within its
dream that they should be consulted on
through the planning process by malden
i think anybody else i need to declare a
personal prejudicial interest in item
five
let's cross the river from me although
i'm in my election that is in london and
i know the people over there
but i believe it's been withdrawn anyway
so just read it out and let the officers
say we're
being drawn or not if it isn't i shall
leave the meeting item five maple leaf
poultry farm maple dean london essex
would officers like to confirm whether
that's been withdrawn or not please
yes chair um thank you chairman that
item has been withdrawn from
consideration at this committee
thank you very much i now move on to
item six
twenty double o 609 stroke out
woodendale manor berlin road orthorn
found on pages 59 to 92 in a moment i
will call
officers to print this item members a
reminder if you wish to speak on this
item please make this known using the
chat function
within this meeting i will then come to
you in turn
please keep your points clear and
concise
hang on a minute
[Music]
sorry about that members members of
public and offices
someone rang uh where
to speak on this item please make this
known use the check function
within the meeting i will then come to
you in turn please
keep your points queensland mr bells
will you present the report please
thank you chair so outline planning
permission with matters of access
appearance layout and scale for
determination
is sought for the demolition of the
existing buildings and erection of 14
dwellings with associated infrastructure
the current proposal follows a previous
application for the same proposal that
was refused at southeast area committee
in june 2019 for five reasons
the amendments to the previous scheme
relate to the inclusion of six
affordable housing units
updated marketing and loss of employment
land information
minor amendments to the layout and three
additional house types are proposed
so here is the location plan
and we have the existing site plan
and the proposed site plan plots one to
six
are the two bed affordable units
and plots 7 to 14 are a mix of the three
and four bedroom units
we've got the existing elevations floor
plan and floor plans of the six
existing buildings to be demolished
this is winterdale manor building a
and we've got building b and building c
and building d and building e
we've got the proposed elevations
floor and roof plans of the two bed
dwellings
and there is proposed to be two rows of
three terraced weddings
i've got the proposed plans for the
three bed dwellings that will occupy
plots eight and twelve
the proposed plans of the three bed
dwellings that would occupy
plot seven and ten
and the proposed plans of the three-bed
dwelling that would occupy a plot 14.
we've then got the proposed plans for
the four-bed dwelling
proposed occupy plot 13
and the proposed plans for the four-bed
dwelling
to occupy plots 9 and 11.
here are the street scene elevations
we've got the existing
proposed and the previously
refused scheme the street scene
elevation you can see here the
built form has intensified in this area
and then we've got the site photos
as previously stated the application is
a resubmission of a previously refused
scheme
whilst the amendments to the scheme have
overcome some of the previous reasons
for refusal
the site lies in an unsustainable
location outside of the defined
settlement boundaries of all thorn
the construction of 14 dwellings spread
across the entire site would result in
the urbanization and domestication
of the site and a sprawl of built form
outside of the settlement boundary
the amendments to the layout and
proposed house types is considered to
have
failed to visually enhance the proposal
and the limited architectural merit of
the development continues to contribute
to the harm
in addition a legal agreement to secure
the affordable housing and rams
contribution
has not been submitted to the council
therefore the application is recommended
for refusal
thank you chair thank you very much we
now have uh
[Music]
under council public participation
scheme we have received three
submissions in line with public
participation scheme i have reviewed
these
and now asked mr johnson lead specialist
development manager to read to the
committee
allocating two minutes for each carry on
mr johnson
thank you chairman uh submission one
from richard bray
on behalf of the applicant
thank you for the opportunity to make
this statement in support of the
development at winterdale manor
we acknowledge that the site is just
outside the defined settlement
boundary and that the council has a
five-year supply of housing
this statement addresses why the
positive aspects of the scheme
should outweigh any harm and why we
consider
that the application should be supported
by members
the site is brownfield in nature and was
used for office
and light industrial purposes it has
been vacant since 2014
and has been extensively marketed and
demonstrated
that this use is no longer sustainable
it is a matter of national planning
policy for land to be
used effectively particularly brownfield
sites
and we consider that the best
alternative use for the site would be
residential
it is immediately adjacent to the
settlement boundary and in our opinion
would not be a detriment to the
intrinsic character and beauty of the
countryside
we have worked hard to address the
concerns raised in previous proposals
for the site
this application is only an outline and
as such
further refinement can be carried out to
the scheme design
at the reserve matter stage and we would
be eager to work with your officers
to ensure this does fit with the
characteristics of the villages at this
stage
the scheme has remained at 14 units
partly to ensure that we accommodate as
many small units as possible
but also to ensure the site can remain
viable and provide the full policy
compliant level of affordable housing
we feel that this is particularly
pertinent as in our research we found
that the whole of
all thorn currently has just eight
affordable homes
our proposal will add significantly to
this
our proposals take the total up to 13
representing a 61
increase in the affordable housing stock
in the village
we are willing to enter into a section
106 agreement for the delivery of these
units
and to secure the ram state the council
has a current 5.27 year supply of
housing
although this should be not this should
not be seen as a ceiling to housing
provision
we contend that where there are strong
circumstances to support additional
windfall sites
that weren't that were not
allocated in the local development plan
then these should be given very careful
consideration
are not dismissed out of hand we
consider winterdale to be such a site
it has no reasonable prospects of being
put back into commercial use
it is immediately adjacent to the
existing settlement boundary on one side
with industrial use on the other and if
developed it will provide much needed
affordable housing
in a village with minimal existing
provision we therefore
urge you to consider these positive
benefits that the scheme can bring to
the village
and wider community and vote to approve
our application
subject to the finalization of the
section 106 agreement
i'll move on to submission two from
councillor paul burgess
chairman of all thorn parish council
our locus is the malden district local
development plan
and its directive the national planning
policy framework
central is an assumption in favor of
sustainable development
this application ticks several boxes
it eliminates an unsightly brownfield
site
is contiguous with the village envelope
is well designed
and sympathetic to the environment
promoted by a ward
entrepreneur hopefully there will be
benefits to the local economy
our opposition is in your notes i should
like to focus on sustainability and the
village envelope
sustainability lacking facilities
hawthorne is designated a smaller
village it is not a sustainable location
for new housing
the planning inspectorate has upheld
multiple refusals by the planning
department
if all thorn is not a sustainable
location for single house projects
it is most certainly it most certainly
is not suitable
for a significant development of 14
dwellings
village envelope all zone is atypical
in having the southern one covers
properties
on a t-shaped configuration on two major
roads
winterdale manor above the northern
envelope
also on a t junction there are multiple
developable sites contiguous with the
envelopes
two sites recently were refused and
planning inspectorate appeals dismissed
this is not an isolated one-off you also
need to be aware
that the village envelopes effectively
are built out
given sustainability issues it seems
unlikely
any variation of the boundaries would be
permitted this application is akin
to the virus covid19 breach in the
membrane of our paris cell
approval means ripping up the ldp good
luck with that
submission three uh from an objector mr
terry
inc winterdale manor has been part of
the village scene since the mid 19th
century
predating most of the existing village
and is described in the response from
the conservation officer
as an old and relatively handsome
building
its designation for business use in
recent years has effectively preserved
the building
and it is shown as the business premises
in the orthom village design statement
which states that the old building
should be sympathetically restored
should this application be approved not
only will today be lost
but the opportunity to provide much
needed sustainable business
accommodation
with minimum travel for the area will go
also
there are plenty of houses in the
pipeline but an application for business
premises in latchington
18 forward slash 01034
by the same applicant as this one which
is included in the pack in front of you
on page 34
section 5.59 laments the lack of
suitable
business accommodation within five miles
of legend
the unconvincing loss of employment land
justification
statement included with this application
has a picture on the front cover
which shows winterdale manor in all its
previous glory
similar to the one in the visual design
statement
before the site was allowed to
deteriorate in the past few years
and the trees were cleared it could look
the same now
with sympathetic restoration and be an
attractive part of the village again
the site is outside the village
development boundary and
16 applications out of 20 full
development in orthorn
since 2013 have been rejected with
unsustainable location
mentioning the reasons for refusal the
proposed development
itself looks too crowded and would not
fit
into the village scene whilst
consideration for screening from the
road
and neighboring properties has taken
place who would be responsible for
maintaining the landscape
area front in the road and police in the
parking on the site
i urge that this application should be
rejected
thank you chairman thank you very much i
need to take some advice from mr lee
please
before i continue mr lee
yep yes i lost connection during the
presentation am i allowed to continue to
do the recommendation or i've got a
withdrawal from the meeting
my understanding is the current
legislation allows for a certain level
of
disconnection um it depends on how much
you feel that you were
obviously i wasn't present i'm not sure
how much you did or didn't
see so the legislation does allow
because obviously remoteness and
internet dropping in and out so
if you consider it was a relatively
small amount i think you can continue
but it's
in your gift to decide that it was
probably about a minute
is that good enough the members happy
that i continue
yeah i've tried to check the download
list
but it's not it's not dropping into my
file at the moment that the attendance
list i mean
download it to look at timings well i'll
continue but not vote at the end of the
meeting okay
does that satisfy everyone's
requirements
the only shops if it was to become a
casting vote chairman
i won't cast a vote and i won't vote at
all what happened so if we need a
casting vote at the end
i won't the vote
will fail sorry i can't do it yeah
exactly so
chairman if you've if you fail to
to cast the application will felt full
okay well i'll have to cast them no no
no
no you don't have to approach him
you don't have to originally right we
won't vote let's just carry on
uh any other officers uh want to comment
before i move the recommendation
now the recommendation is set out within
report is as follows
recommendation that planning application
winterdale manor burnham road author be
refused for the reasons that's detailed
in section 8
of the report if any member wishes to
second that motion please turn on your
video
unlock your microphone and state your
name now
seconded councillor bell yes bill thank
you very much
if any member wishes thank you if it now
invite members to make any comments on
the report
members okay answer him we've got
cancer boys and counselor bell wishing
to right
voice first and then councillor bell
please
thank you chairman um first of all the
um applicant's agent uh mentioned social
housing in the village
um so i better declare that
i'm a trustee of that social housing um
that's that's the first point i
didn't know that i needed would need to
say
that at the start of the
making um
as you can see i actually called this
application
in um that's correct i thought that
the previous application come to the
committee and i thought that it was
reasonable that this application should
also come
to the community um
was the affordable housing element uh
now ortho other than those
um arms houses has got no
other form of social housing as was
pointed out by
the applicant's agent i think
now allthorn
does need social housing
force for the young people
of the village however our
president's system would not allow any
social housing
that we may grant to be
conditioned to people from
the village so for that reason um i
would
at this stage not support this
application however while i'm speaking
about the affordable housing
we have got an agreement
with other local authorities
about our housing affordable housing
and who has the affordable housing
which before the world turned upside
down
i thought that we were going to
make sure that the affordable housing
in our district which is not
uh inconsiderable at that stage
we would be able to appoint people
from the district to rather than have
the chance of people from outside
those are my reasons um for
bringing this to the
the committee chairman uh as i
said that although we need
affordable housing in our villages
we can't guarantee that the village
people will get them
so therefore i think i will support the
officer's recommendation
thank you thank you councillor bell now
is it next
thank you yes thank you mr chairman yeah
with all
due respect to councillor boyce because
something's affordable doesn't make it
sustainable
if it is in a sustainable location
i think the offices have prepared
excellent reports on this
and i think we should support their
recommendation it contradicts all the
plans it contradicts
the ldp and many many policies
so i yep i'm in favor of refusing this
application
thank you mr chairman thank you anybody
else wish to speak
thank you chairman um like counselor
boyce uh now the word social has
mentioned
in in what was read out to us um i will
be declaring i'm also
a trustee of an arms health charity and
actually i think
um i have read the previous report
minutes and everything it looks a
previous application i've read this
report chairman
i think actually um councillor bell has
really probably
summed up what i was going to say and i
bear very much
in mind the author there's been several
applications in author not on this site
necessarily elsewhere as well
whereby various applicants did go to
appeal
and the authority has won every one of
those
um appeals in that it was deemed to be
by the inspector
different inspectors that all thorn was
not a sustainable location
and having the railway and all that
which was made by arguments as well
um for reasons explained in all those
appeal statements wasn't seen as a
deciding factor that all thorn is
unsustainable so
i must support the officer's
recommendation unlike councillor bell i
thought it was a very good
report a fair report
thank you penny anybody else cancer
stamp
counselor yes just ditto chairman i
think it's an excellent report i commend
the officer who wrote it
and i totally agree with the officer
recommendation on this one chairman
thank you
thank you um nobody else
no chairman berna can we now take the
vote on the officer's recommendation
please and i will not be voting
berna can you take the vote yes yes i'm
just getting the um
voting sheet up chairman okay sorry
no that's okay please um
bear with me for a moment because i was
downloading the attendance sheet
thank you
so members i will call you in
alphabetical order starting with
counselor belle
for master boyce
for cancer channel
for the officer recommendation thank you
bernard
councillor hall
cast the hull
council stamp for berna thank you very
much
members that's five for the officer's
recommendation
none against and no abstentions that is
duly carried
uh item seven any other item business
that the chairman of the committee
decides are urgent
i have only one thing to mention thank
you very much for allowing me to chair
the meeting for these few times
and i hope richard will be back for the
next month and
from then on we'll have to wait and see
what happens thank you
close of the meeting members thank you
for opportunity to this afternoon i draw
your
the meeting to a close at uh 13
29 as the meeting is now closed member
advised not to enter in any further
discussion on this forum
and please leave the meeting promptly
thank you thank you